donc monsieur monsieur minier donc les
recherches sur le terrain se sont
abandonnés considérant que depuis un an
et demi beaucoup de choses ont été
faites vous l'avez dit vous avez pour
l'instant échoué dans la recherche du
canard puisque vous êtes persuadé qu'il
ya un cadavre qu'il est quelque part
qu'il est dans la zone dans laquelle
vous avez cherché mais pour l'instant
vous l'avez pas trouvé tout à fait elles
sont pas sont donnés on joue pas je veux
pas dire la même chose que vous
elles sont interrompues pour le moment
faute de nouveaux éléments mais sachez
qu'elles vont elles vont elles vont
durer le temps qu'il faudra jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à une commande une action
publique qui s'éteindra mais jamais
parce qu'en fait on doit toujours des
éléments dans ok tu as trouvé donc il ya
encore quelques recherches à faire au
niveau du doubs qui ne sont pas
effectués pour le des raisons de
commandes de climat mais une fois qu'on
aura terme et bien sûr qu'on rendra
dossier au magistrat instructeur et puis
ensuite tout élément nouveau bien est ce
bien sûr porter une reconnaissance sera
l'objet de recherches poussées
évidemment vous considérez que par
rapport à tout ce qui a déjà été fait
n'est pas sérieux de continuer à
ratisser cette zone qui est pour
l'instant relativement restreinte et que
dans cette zone vous allez tout fait moi
je pense qu'on a on a fait vraiment du
un gros gros travail de recherches sur
le terrain et de me paraît elle se forge
pourrait pas utile de continuer parce
que on a vraiment fait le maximum
vous avez là la preuve absolue que donc
cet homme est le coupable et qui l'a
assassiné
cette fille est ensuite dissimulé le
corps quelque part dans la zone dans
laquelle vous cherchez cette thèse a de
toute manière oui on a courbé sur elle
comme instructeur et on erronées sur la
thèse de l'assassinât bien sûr donc là
il reste quelques recherches des
plongeurs
la campagne se termine là aussi vous
aviez j'imagine des espoirs qu'ils sont
déçus oui on est déçu mais on est
toujours déçu de ne pas les vannes aux
fins notre enquête nous à nous amener à
trouver de nombreux éléments il manque
le corps de naomi et puis c'est surtout
pour la famille que j'ai une pensée
puisque c'est très bien que s'ils sont
encore c'est difficile de faire le deuil
de son de ses enfants et de sa famille
et ses proches donc moi je souhaite
vraiment qu'on retrouve ce corps pour
cette raison-là déjà et puis que j'ai
aussi démontré à houphouët aux mises en
examen qui en fait on a on à poursuivre
notre enquête de telle sorte qu'on
arrive à la à cette conclusion qu'il a
bien que cette jeune fille et qu'il est
bien déposer l'endroit où on cherche moi
est-ce que vous expliquer le fait goudé
pas encore trouvé de de cada vous avez
affaire à quelqu'un qui arrive certes de
l'étranger qui connaît pas le terrain
qui vient quand même quelques jours
avant donc qui prend des repères qui
manifestement quelqu'un d'assez
intelligent en tout cas il savait ce
qu'il faisait
enfin comment vous expliquez vous être
doublé un petit peu parce que la doubler
il a joué de facteur chance certainement
mais en tout cas il a bien préparé c'est
son axe son acte puisque de toute
manière il a fait des recherches de
longues recherches avant de venir et
quand il est arrivé en france était
vraiment dans le but de ces sept cette
jeune fille et il avait tout mis en
oeuvre pour que ce soit bien bien bien
cynique bien dissimulé donc moins
franchement laquelle on a affaire à
quelqu'un d'autre de machiavélique et de
très intelligent et qui qui qui lui nous
a donné du fil à retorde notamment dans
la recherche du corps de la roumanie
c'est sûr tous les moyens ont été mises
en oeuvre
c'est à dire moi il ya un humain moyen
technique voire technologique et en
véhicule aussi enfin parce que ça va
j'ai été jusqu'à on a commencé par les
avions hélicoptères la gendarmerie nous
a beaucoup aidés puisque
en fait rappelle alors comment alors
plongeurs à leur personnel qui gérait
sonar on a fait également appel aux
chiens de recherche de cadavres on a
fait également appel aux sapeurs
pompiers pour les cherche un cadavre un
peu plus récents on a fait appel à
l'esprit alors qu'on a fait on a fait en
effet rendre au travail
je dirais qu'en total on totalise plus
de plus de 1000 heures 1500 heures de
recherches
au total m'a fait appel également à des
jeunes collègues de l'école de
montbéliard pour faire des ratissages
dans des zones bien précises dans la
forêt de chaux donc c'est un gros
travail on n'a pas mis en exergue parce
qu'on voulait rester discret puisque on
le voulait avoir l'assurance de ne pas
se tromper sur le sur le site conques
ont fouillé mais non on a fait on a fait
un gros travail je pense qu'on a mis
tous les moyens tous les moyens en
oeuvre qu'on pouvait mettre pour votre
sept jeunes filles ont la situation elle
semble un peu bloquée alors même si pour
la famille c'est quand même important de
retrouver le corps mais la situation est
semble quand même bloqué parce que oui
c'est ce qu'on est bloqué mais vous
savez tout est possible il suffit d'un
promeneur d'un pêcheur je ne sais pas
et puis peut être qu'avec les conditions
qui m'a dit qu'il ya eu les fortes crues
les choses comme ça peut-être qu'on
retrouve à des parties du corps de la
victime
un peu plus loin que les recherches que
nous on commence à pousser quoi vous
imaginez pas du tout qui brouille les
pistes par exemple dans ce coin
justement du pays de nos dols l'a1 que
non pas sans désagrément enquête qui
laisse à penser que quand il a quitté le
secteur ils étaient seuls voilà c'est
comme ça je peux rouler plus n'aura donc
pour nous c'est clair c'est clair que
voisin car il ya sans doute un canal il
est dans le secteur dans lequel vous
allez chercher
oui à pratiquement 100 % venir mais bon
le mans qui nous manque les déclarations
de ce monsieur